[Music]
all right world here we go
jordan peterson ben shapiro dave rubin
we got a lot to do we got about two
hours to do it i thought how am i gonna
start this thing I could ask you guys
how you're doing we could dive right
into some deep topics but then I thought
no let's do something else
a lot of people don't seem to like us
that is a weird thing we've been
bouncing around quite literally all over
the world the last couple months and
we're meeting thousands and thousands
hundreds of thousands of people at this
point who are decent good people from
every walk of life trying to find some
answers and meet other people that think
like them or don't think like them but
just but just want to find some decency
in this world and yet the online world
just seems relentlessly hateful and you
probably get more hate than anyone else
so I thought that would just be an
interesting way to start this like just
as three people that I think are
basically trying to put some decency out
there just sort of the level of anger
and hate that we get oh go to you for it
does it bother you anymore oh yeah I
mean I try to shield myself to it from
it to some degree
I mean I'm certainly decreased that
amount of time that I'm spending reading
Twitter comments to pretty much zero
yeah
the I find the the contentious
interchanges with journalists I would
say are the most stressful things that I
do and they usually rattled me up for a
day or two afterwards even though I
would say they're still worth doing but
the the here's the thing okay so a
couple of observations the first is a
lot of the pejorative comments that have
been aimed at me for example have been
that my followers are a bunch of angry
young white men and so I'd like to take
that apart a little bit I mean the first
thing I've learned in the last month or
so thought through is that I'm done
making any sort of apologies whatsoever
for the fact that most of the people who
are watching my youtube videos
our men there's nothing wrong with
talking to men and if men happened to be
benefiting from what I'm discussing then
so much the better
women have to live with men and so
that's of great benefit to women and
there are plenty of women writing me
telling me that and also meeting me at
these talks saying exactly the same
thing and then they're not angry so and
how do I know that well as you just
pointed out we have spoken to 250,000
people in seven months
how many incidents of anger have we had
I mean when I tell you literally none
zero zero right is zero they the shows
have been love yes yeah yeah they're
very very positive yeah so and we had
one heckler who was obviously not a fan
in one venue I wasn't even at that show
so the the lectures couldn't possibly be
more peaceful or positive as far as I'm
concerned and so and then the people
there aren't particularly young I would
say the average ages is somewhere
between 30 and 40 and there's plenty of
older people and especially in the u.s.
now it's at least a third women for what
that's worth and I think that's because
women are buying more of the books in
Europe it was still more men but that's
because in many of those countries the
book had only come out recently and you
know it's definitely not the way the
media portrays it they're making it seem
like it's ninety ten I mean I owe you at
the beginning of the show when I
reference something about that I usually
say it's 6040 yeah sometimes it's a
little more in one way or the other but
it's certainly not the way well I think
a lot of the vitriol is see I was I just
finished reading another book on
post-modernism an oxford book on
post-modernism and on Derrida in
particular and like there really was an
attempt on the part of the post
modernists and and this is allied I
think with their fundamental Marxism to
demolish the idea of the autonomous
individual so for example one of the
things that's really interesting about
the current free speech debate is that
it really isn't a debate because you
have to be in the judeo-christian /
Enlightenment tradition to believe in
free speech because to believe in free
speech you have to believe that there
are autonomous individuals who have
their own viewpoints who can
spontaneously generate creative ideas
and then who can engage in an active
dialogue in a in a in a manner that that
that consider
of fundamental goodwill and truth and
that you can change each other's
opinions and that you can come to a
negotiated agreement you have to believe
all of that including the autonomous
individual in that concept the logos
which is what dirt Derrida was so so
what he criticized so heavily that idea
of logo centrism you have to believe in
the autonomous individual and the
postmodernist and the neo-marxists they
don't they believe that the individual
is a mouthpiece for a power assembly and
that there's no such thing as free
speech which is why they no platform
right it's not well it is it's so that
debate about free speech is way deeper
than who should be allowed to talk the
debate about free speech is whether or
not there is such a thing as free speech
outside the power game that neo-colonial
Europeans are playing and so what I'm
doing and what you're doing with me and
I think what everybody in the IDW is
doing to some degree is speaking to
people as if they are autonomous
individuals who are the bedrock of
civilization and sovereignty and that is
absolute anathema to the radical left
and so they they see that as a
fundamental challenge which it is so the
individual is the fundamental challenge
I think that's perfect for you because
it's like you as an individual ben
shapiro you get more hate online than
pretty much anyone and it's not just
that you get hate it's the nature of the
hate where that you're a white
supremacist you happen to be wearing a
yarmulke which is a little confusing you
know that you are that you're a nazi or
the rest of it and it's like i know
you're okay with criticism but it's not
criticism that they're leveling it's
just endless hate it endless
over-the-top okay well that's the weird
you know if you're a good person you try
to be a good person every time you
receive a piece of criticism as a good
person your first response should be did
I do something wrong was it made right
and yeah and as somebody who's trying to
get better at being a human and also
just at what I do I spend an awful lot
of time trying to look at those
criticisms and say okay is that
reasonable and usually it's something
from you know ten years ago there's like
okay yeah I should have done that better
that was those stupid I shouldn't have
said that right yeah but it isn't always
10 years ago for you because you even
had that nice moment in this studio
where you said that you have a sort of
public and private position on
addressing trans people by pronouns that
they want
right you don't want to be bludgeoned
into doing it but privately if you knew
someone that was trans and respected
them of course you would use the pronoun
them right in the same way that I would
do that with with anybody about anything
generally if I'm in a private
conversation with somebody and I don't
when I want the conversation to progress
beyond something that's unrelated then
I'm not going to go out of my way to
offend them because it's pointless but
in a public conversation where the
expressed topic being discussed is human
biology then I'm not going to give in to
the argument that I have now given up my
argument by using the pronoun of your
choice because that is undercutting my
own argument we're now in a public
debate that's a different forum but that
idea is that you are unsympathetic and I
think this goes to the fundamental
conceit of folks on the Left which is
that they are more sympathetic human
beings and people who oppose them
politically or unsympathetic human
beings and this goes back to the
individual versus communitarian
distinction for the left if you're an
individual this means that you are
inherently unsympathetic to others
because your individuality stands
against the collective if you are you're
a member of the collective then you can
show that by your the amount of sympathy
that you have for other people and so I
think but also for the collective it's
also a very weird form of sympathy right
because the collective doesn't suffer
individuals suffer right you know and
that's a and then the other thing that's
interesting about that reflexive
identification of sympathy with virtue
is that it's actually extraordinarily
immature as far as I'm concerned because
most complex problems aren't aren't
solvable by reflexive sympathy and
reflexive sympathy is more like it it's
more like an instinct it's more like
anger it's more like jealousy or rage or
love for that matter it doesn't have
that cognitive component that enables
you to take apart complex systems and to
analyze them and determine what the
problem is and what X Ellucian might
look like and then to lay that out in a
cold and calculated manner towards some
positive end it's this automatic
assumption that because you're
overwhelmed with pity let's say that
that somehow makes you morally virtuous
and it not only does it not make you
morally virtuous it's often the case
that that and this is the big Freudian
observation that that all-encompassing
pity actually has a devouring component
and that's that overprotectiveness
while the jonathan height and and
lukianov have been writing about for
example and it's very it's it's that
interferes with the development of
people's autonomy and so the reflexive
idea that because you're a sympathetic
person you're good right is is bad
enough in addition to the fact that well
all the sympathy is on the radical left
which it certainly isn't well i think
that one of the things that hi talks
about and this is where i think the left
has taken advantage in so many areas and
i'd say the left and I don't mean people
who are liberal I always make this
distinction there are people who are on
the Left thanks Mauro are liberal right
and this is this Dave's point all the
time if you are for free speech but you
disagree with me about tax rates you're
liberal if you're somebody who's on the
Left and you want to shut down debate
because you fundamentally believe that
free speech is a conceit of the power
structure right then then you are on the
left
but what Haight says and he's correct
about this is that in any conversation
you have with anybody there's sort of an
entry gateway to the conversation and
that is showing that you have good will
so showing sympathy is one form of doing
that so what the Left likes to do is
prevent the conversation from happening
by preventing you from appearing as a
sympathetic human being meaning that so
for example when I talk about
transgenderism the first thing that gets
thrown at me is you don't care about
transgender people why are we even
having this conversation
you're trying to be mean you're trying
to create violence against transgender
folks and this is why this language is
constantly used because if we accept
that I have tremendous sympathy for
people who are suffering from what is by
any measure a disorder and if I say that
we have to look at sympathy for these
people and try and find the best
scientific solutions and try and figure
out what's best for society generally
not just for the transgender folks but
for kids who are teaching who can be
easily confused about gender or if we're
looking at what's the best solution for
doctors who there's an article in The
New York Times like last week with a
person suggesting that doctors should be
forced to perform transgender surgery
simply based on wants not even based on
an assessment of need the doctor should
not be able to assess whether somebody
needs the transgender surgery or whether
basically the situation in Ontario
already in Canada yeah it mean it's on
demand it's it's just like any other
optional surgery yeah I mean this sort
of stuff has real societal consequences
and to be and so what the left will do
is they don't want to talk about the
societal consequences instead what they
do is they say you're not welcome in the
conversation because you're
unsympathetic and so this is usually
what's thrown to me and you know fairly
enough in the sense that my slogan
facts don't care about your feelings but
what I mean by that is not that you
shouldn't care about other people it's
that in the end the solutions that are
going to lead to better lives are not
going to be feelings based they're going
to be facts based this does not mean I
have to be an unsympathetic human being
so for example there's a story that I
really haven't told publicly because I
don't like to tell these stories
publicly because you know Maimonides has
a base of principle of charity which is
the best form of charity is anonymous
charity because then you don't get
credit for it's all right I don't want
to make it seem like this happened
simply because I was trying to take
credit for it but several weeks ago I
was speaking at a university which will
remain unnamed for anonymity for
anonymity reasons and I was in this
topic came up a transgender person got
up in the microphone and asked a
question and the conversation kind of
went sideways the person suggested they
start talking about their personal story
and I started kind of picking holes in
the personal story a little bit and it's
probably an exchange that I could have
handled better but in any case the
person got very upset and started to cry
and then left and this is all on tape
and it was one of those situations where
because I give speeches in in Q&A forums
and because there's a lot of videos of
me destroying people there's one of
those situations where if the tape comes
out it gets five million views and it
Shapiro destroys transgender right Ryan
I don't want that to be what happens at
my lectures if there's gonna be a ship
Hiro destroys video which we don't even
cut then I would like it to be like just
a rational exchange where everybody
leaves feeling good about the exchange
and somebody lost in somebody one fine
this was something different the person
got it visibly emotionally upset very
upset and the people who are running the
event happened to know who this person
was so I called the person up on the
phone and I said that really didn't go I
wanted to go you know I have my public
position but that's that doesn't mean I
don't have sympathy for you I went to
the organizers of the event I had them
cut that part out of the tape because
there's no reason this person should be
exposed to ridicule and then I had
coffee with the person next morning to
ensure the person was doing okay
emotionally okay that's not coming from
a place if I don't care about people
this is coming from a place of these are
important vital public conversations
then shutting down those conversations
by saying that I don't care about a
human being that I don't care about what
happens to people is the nastiest form
of no platforming because it's not just
saying you know this is a platform of
your views because your views are so
terrible and so awful it's saying that
your views are inherently evil
yeah they're inherently sociopath and
you are - and you are - and that's and
that's something that I I think is
actually a form of [ __ ] Laurie beyond
comprehension
that you can care for people I think
that you can care for individuals and I
mean one of the things that's been
characterizing the tour that we've been
doing is that like when I'm lecturing I
don't lecture to the audience I lecture
to individuals and I'm not lecturing to
them either that's that's the wrong way
because I always include myself in the
discussion so if we're talking about
ethical principles and how they might be
what would you call it put forward or or
found it more more solidly than I'm
always including myself in the list of
perpetrators who need some improvement
right so it's just discussing with
people one at a time even though they
happen to be very large audiences and
then when I see people afterwards
because I meet about a hundred and fifty
people after each talk then I get not a
huge amount of time but enough time to
make personal contact with each person
and I'm very careful to do that
extremely carefully because I'm very
happy they're there and they often tell
me a story about you know how they were
suffering in some way or things weren't
set right in their life and that they've
been trying to develop a vision to aim
high it's something that's worth aiming
at which is part of the advantage of
hierarchies right which the which is
something we should talk about because
you can't aim at something without
privilege in it over something else and
if you don't have anything tame at then
you don't have any purpose in your life
and that's a bloody catastrophe so
anyways they come up with a vision and
they're trying to be more responsible
and then the the the individualism
aspect of this is you know I've I've
outlined two people that they're to take
responsibility for themselves which is
not the same thing as to be individually
selfish and to do that in a way that
also makes them responsible for their
family and to do that in a way that also
makes them responsible for the community
so the individualism isn't the selfish
individualism that the leftists or
criticism criticizing by any stretch of
the imagination it's the individual
positioned in an iterated game right
that includes them as individuals
stretched across time so there's already
a collective in that in some sense and
then them in relationship to family and
the community but stemming from the
individual award which I think is part
and parcel of the judeo-christian
enlightenment philosophy anyways these
people come and tell me
a story and they say they were in a bad
place and that things have improved a
lot and they're kind of sad about the
bad place part and vision visibly upset
often and then they tell me how things
are improved and they're really happy
about that and it's very touching and
emotional and that's where the that's
where caring takes place that's right at
the level of the individual I went into
a wholefoods yesterday this happens
quite often and so I was there and two
of the guys from behind the meat counter
came out separately and they said that
they had been watching my lectures and
one of them talked about the fact that
you know he has a 7 year old son and
that he wants to do right by him then
he's been looking really hard for
ethical and moral guidance and that he's
been reading and listening to my book
and concentrating on the parts about
telling the truth and not lying and I'm
having these conversations with people
one at a time about them striving hard
to develop an ethical philosophically
grounded ethical perspective you know
and it's it's so interesting to see this
happening and to see who's doing it this
is this is I think an important point is
that I get asked a lot because I do get
so much criticism and flak I get asked a
lot have I ever been confronted in
public because I got in public you know
with my family to Disneyland went on
Thanksgiving to Disneyland and I got you
know C accosted not not cost it but
people came up to me because they like
my stuff or they enjoy it and they want
to take pictures probably happened 35 to
40 times over the course of the day and
they asked me have I ever had there ever
been a situation where somebody came up
to you and said something mean or nasty
yeah I can't think of one I can't think
of one time this has ever happened now
online that's all I get so there the
point here is that when it comes to
individuals who are affected you know
who actually and who actually feel good
or bad about you
yeah it's a collective mob mentality
that allows people to protest you and
then protest me and then that is picked
up the mob mentality is picked up by
individual journalists who see
themselves as sort of champions of the
people hmm
broadly but not champions of individuals
because they still can't find the
individual who's been victimized by
Jordan Peterson you still can't find the
individual who's been victimized by Dave
Rubin or an individual who's been
victimized by the entropy row you can't
find those people so instead what it
becomes is oh it's a broader group
that's victimized but none of those
people have ever come to me personally
and said you victimized me you hurt me
because they can't
a situation in which this is happened
well I always loved I always love when
they say that we're radicalizing people
and it's like if I open up my inbox I'm
getting emails from all sorts of people
usually on the right who say that they
were a little more extreme on the right
yeah because they see a decent liberal
who will treat them with respect they've
modified their opinions but what do you
think about this just at a at a
psychological level the disconnect
between what seems to be happening in
the real world on a day to day basis and
the way a huge amount of people are
behaving online what do you think is
psychologically well it's that's a tough
one I mean it could easily be like if
you think of venues like Twitter
let's take Twitter as an example we
don't understand we don't really
understand much about how people
communicate period psychologically what
one of the things that psychologists do
know is that if there's any distancing
between you and a person so for example
if you're inside a car you're much more
likely to act in an impulsive and
hostile manner and that because one of
the things that seems to mitigate
against that impulsive hostility is
whatever mechanisms kick in when you're
face to face with someone so those might
be mechanisms that are associated with
innate sympathy for example and so that
regulates your behavior and because most
of the time in our evolutionary history
you were interacting directly one-on-one
with someone that seemed to work out
quite well cavemen were they had to
carve in insults into the into walls and
that that took a lot of time and so but
on Twitter like it could easily be I
read this little article here a while
back showing what words needed to be in
content for those to be most likely
retweeted and they were almost all
high-level negative emotion words and so
it could be you have this huge pool of
people and then it might be that only
the person who's in a bad mood and is
irritated that day or a sort of
chronically like that or disposition ly
like that let's say and who is
specifically angry about something that
they saw right then is likely to tweet
and so that gives you this tremendously
skewed view of the of the consensus
because you assume like if you if
there's a hundred people that show up in
a mob outside your door you assume that
there's more than
a hundred people mad at you right there
there a representative of a much larger
group on on Twitter you can't tell if
the 30 people who say snarky things
especially anonymously to you you can't
tell if they're representative at all
and they're likely not and you know that
that very narrow bandwidth at 140 or 280
characters might also be something that
really facilitates angry impulsive
responding and so we don't understand
any of this psychologic time and I think
there's something else happening too and
that is that both Twitter and Facebook
all social media is basically something
different in human history in the sense
that it's just a crowd without a purpose
so it's a crowd looking for a purpose
meaning that throughout human history we
actually had to have face-to-face
interactions with people the only reason
you would show up in a crowd is because
the crowd had a purpose so where were
you typically doing this as you were
going to a church right everybody was
there to worship everybody was there
with a common goal in mind right you
were a member of the army and so there's
a common goal in mind any time you were
getting together was because there's a
party so everybody was there for the
party twitter is legitimately people
waking up and just I want to interact
with other humans there are no other
humans around and so I'm here and you're
here and we're all here and look
somebody just said something odd there's
a common purpose let's jump on that and
then there's this back-slapping effect
of the person said something and I mean
we all use Twitter so we all know that
if you are the most dangerous thing
about Twitter than most if I could do
anything with Twitter I would get rid of
the mentions tab the reason being
because if you are a if you're just a
human behavior it encourages bad
behavior especially because it
encourages you to be looking and seeing
how people are responding to you because
as human beings we're constantly looking
to see how people are responding to us
and so this is just generally a good
thing right it's generally a good thing
except that it's it's an ego machine yes
I sound sorry because the key one of the
keys to being a good person is to
recognize most people aren't thinking
about you 95% of the time right you're
not that important as a human and so if
in order for you be important to
actually do something important but
because Twitter functions in such a way
that all you get is that feedback loop
it encourages you more and more to look
for more of that feedback makes you feel
good I mean you get a little endorphin
rush every time there's a nice comments
about you you're fresh you're a fresh
form or nice comments that's
happen in real life there's never a
situation in real life in which that
happens when it does it's a major life
event it's a wedding
it's Bar Mitzvah right it's something
where people are collectively
celebrating you but on Twitter everybody
is collectively celebrating everybody
else and the people who issue the
strongest opinions are the people who
receive both the most condemnation and
the most celebration so in a weird way
not that we want people to go into their
bubbles but are these town squares
almost there almost too big to actually
ever function properly so every week
there's another story where Jack says
I'm gonna get rid of the likes or I'm
gonna get rid of follower accounts and
they're always trying to float these
ideas to manipulate how we all behave
with each other but in an odd way having
everyone from everywhere on these
platforms really doesn't make sense in
some bizarre way I'm not saying that we
should be a separate plan well there's
no community yeah
because your names right so it's like we
need something that has community I
think but then the danger has been our
little equity right I mean they're the
need it's fascinating because if you
look in other places the internet just
structurally the way that the community
works is a little bit different the way
that it works or it used to work ten
years ago when people actually visited
websites directly was that you'd have
something like at National Review the
corner and it was a bunch of people you
know like us sitting around and
discussing ideas back and forth and back
and forth like a group blog yeah and it
was restricted to the people who were
discussing the ideas and then below our
video game board or anything exactly and
then below that you'd have the comment
section which was all about those
particular conversations because Twitter
is fragmented there's no actual
conversation taking place on Twitter
there's me saying something and you're
responding to and me not responding to
you mostly and then be tweeting another
thought and then you're responding to it
and the idea of having a long-form
conversation every time it happens on
Twitter at the end of the conversation
you find someone saying this isn't the
appropriate place to have a long-form
conversation if we're gonna do that we'd
be on a pod right we'd be writing each
other letters like this isn't that this
isn't the way to do that and even when
I'm discussing with my Peters even when
I'm talking with people on the Left who
I talk with on the phone instead of
having a conversation on Twitter about
the topic I will call pick up the phone
and call them and have the conversation
because you can't have a good
conversation on Twitter you just can how
much of this is connected to one of the
things that you've brought up in many of
the lectures which is that we're just
getting
information so much faster right now we
can not only just open up our phone and
have basically the world right there but
we can listen to podcasts in
double-speed which if you listen to
Pierrot in double speed is you go back
inside extra but yeah I wasn't doing
half but that just the nature of the
technology how it's just speeding up our
ability to take in information that
maybe we haven't evolved faster well
it's also we're taking in kind of pseudo
information because it it looks like
information but it's really low
resolution and so you get a lot of it
but it's not it's not real knowledge
it's like there was a funny New Yorker
cartoon where a wife asked her husband
do you know that or do you just Google
know it right right and so and the but
the the the the thing about those those
those shallow media interactions is that
you also don't have to take any
responsibility for them you know
especially if you're anonymous and that
also brings out the worst in people you
know and and and the the trolling
phenomena
I mean one of the things you notice
about children for example is if
children don't get enough good attention
they'll certainly go after bad attention
because the fundamental human currency
is attention and it's it's one thing to
be hated but it's another thing entirely
to be ignored and I would say generally
speaking if you put people in a corner
and you made them choose you know if
they were if they had knowledge that was
transparent to themselves said what
would you rather be ignored or hate it
they take hated because at least then
you exist because you exist at least in
some part in your relationship to other
people and so some of the bad behavior
is is rewarded precisely for that reason
is that it does draw attention and that
does make you signify I mean you think
about the people who do Highness crimes
like the the school shooters people like
that who do these things that are almost
inconceivable a huge part of the drive
for that is fantasies about notoriety
and and and and and the emergence from
obscurity and anonymity even though it's
it's notorious it's hatred the idea is
I'd rather be dead and infamous than
alive and know
which by the way you I think were one of
the first websites to say we're not
going to publish these people yeah and
then we're giving them exactly what they
exactly like there have been I don't
take credit is like the first there
several names escape me but they're
there other people who have been
promoting this for a while but yeah I
was late to it we should have done it
earlier and I talked to the Canadian
Broadcasting Corporation about that
about ten years ago about the idea that
publicizing the names of these killers
is precisely one of the mechanisms that
ensures that it will continue to happen
and there's no doubt about that now how
do how to mitigate against that is very
complicated
I mean and that does tie to a deeper
conversation that did you see this this
study those from the CDC that came out
of it again for the second straight year
life expectancy in the United States
dropped so he had consistent life
expectancy increases in the United
States for 150 years and now for the
first time in American modern American
history life expectancy is now dropped
for two years in a row and that
specifically due to two phenomena one is
the increase in heroin overdoses and the
other is suicide both the suicide is now
at record rates in the modern era and we
had 70,000 heroin overdoses opiate Oprah
overdoses last year I think was 50,000
the year before and so you're starting
to see life expectancy decline there's a
crisis of meaning and that's why and I
think that part of the resistance to
particularly I think Jordan but I think
also to me and to anyone else in the IDW
who's at least searching for meaning is
that the left has been saying for a long
time that we found the meaning right the
meaning was do what you want to do the
meaning was no responsibility do what
you want to do that's the meaning the
meaning is rebelling against the system
and when it turns out that a lot of
people don't find meaning in that that
there is in my perspective a god-shaped
hole in people's heart that is being
filled by hatred and polarization and
tribalism or that you just can't do it
forever no one can maintain that that
level forever of trying to tear
everything down well it's also there's
also there's there's there's there's
nothing in it especially as your
opponent weakens you know this is we
thought maybe we talked a little bit
about hierarchies so you know the thing
about one of the things a hierarchy does
is is fundamentally is put some things
above other things and you think well
the left criticize the left criticism of
that which is a valid criticism is that
if you erect a hierarchy
well let let me let me step one step
back we'll walk through this in a bit of
a sequence okay so the first proposition
would be we do have real problems people
because people suffer and like we have
real problems and we would also like to
solve them and that solutions do exist
and that if you have a solution and then
you implement it socially and so you
have to get people to cooperate and
compete around the solution you're gonna
produce a hierarchy and if the hierarchy
is valid then the people who are the
best at producing this solution to the
problem are going to lead the hierarchy
okay so that would be a conservative
right-wing position it's like we need
hierarchies they privilege values and
they're necessary to solve problems and
there is a relationship between the
ability to solve the problem and the
structure of the hierarchy okay so the
one we'd say that's true when
hierarchies are functioning well okay so
that's the right-wing viewpoint and then
the left wingers would say wait a second
your hierarchy gets rigid over time and
ossifies and can be occupied by people
who use power instead of competence to
dominate it and they do that unfairly
and they warped the structure of the
hierarchy and that makes it difficult
for people to gain entry including
talented people and then the hierarchy
itself as a structure has a problem
because dispossessed people tend to
stack up at the bottom and that all
seems relevant and true right so then
then you could say well you need the
right because you need the hierarchies
and and and they need to be implemented
and that's what managers and
administrators do that's what
conscientious people do because they're
hierarchically oriented and it's a very
efficient way of operating and people
are actually happier within hierarchies
because there's an identifiable chain of
command but then the left has its
position which is yeah but you got to
watch out for the dispossessed because
they're the majority and you have to
make sure the thing doesn't degenerate
towards tyranny so then I think the
political discussion is the left and the
right constantly eyeing each other to
make sure that the hierarchical
structures maintain their good health
and so and that's why freedom of speech
is necessary okay so the now the the
issue with that let's see if I can get
back to where I was I was going with
this to begin with
oh yes the issue with that is that if
you were just a rebel you say well we're
going to criticize the system whatever
that is so that's a very big thing to
begin with
you demolish that value hierarchy and
and the idea of value hierarchies as
such but then that puts you in a
terrible conundrum and this is what I've
been focusing on in my public lectures
isn't it
if you accept the essential idea that
life is suffering and life is suffering
tainted by malevolence which i think is
an even more accurate formulation you
have a fundamental existential problem
and that's the suffering and then you
need a meaning to set against that to to
to to fortify you against the
catastrophe so and if you demolish the
hierarchies then you have no meaning
there's nothing to strive for and
without that meaning you're anxious and
overwhelmed by definition we know that
neuro psychologically because purpose
boxes you it right it gives you a game
to play and rules to follow and then
purpose gives you something to aim at
and positive emotion and so the problem
with what the left is offering and I
think this is actually the kind of
problem that sam Harris and the Atheist
types are running into too is it's like
well okay where's the purpose well we
don't have one it's just rebellion
against the unfair hierarchy it's like
yeah but the hierarchy also provides you
with value well that's okay it's cost to
so high we're gonna demolish the
hierarchy well then you're left with
nothing well but no you're not left with
nothing because you're left what you're
left with is an inalienable suffering so
not nothing that's the suicide and I
think that the left solution to that has
been intersectionality meaning what
they've done is they're just taking that
higher or they've taken the hierarchy
and they've said the hierarchy is bad
because it's ossified and it's terrible
and it's not just that they've destroyed
the hierarchy and then we are all
leveled it's that they have inverted the
hierarchy in certain ways that merit
itself has become a sign that you are an
exploiter yes right that if you are that
if you're on the top of the hierarchy
then it's because you did something
wrong to get there and you hurt you're
going to get there you're there for the
the last shall be first we're gonna just
take this triangle I'm gonna flip it
upside down so that way the cables are
the bottom or at the top so I think that
I think there's something absolutely
fundamental there too because I've been
trying to understand what the core issue
is that drives the pathological left and
I think it is the story of Cain and Abel
fundamentally is that it's it's jealousy
of the successful and and the worst kind
of
successful person as it turns out it
from a jealousy perspective think
speaking psychologically it's like if
you got your power arbitrarily if you
inherited it or you got it unfairly well
you're kind of annoying but you're not
that annoying because you're not that
good
you're just lucky right and so I can be
jealous of you because you're lucky and
that's unfair but you're just as
reprehensible as me right but then let's
take the alternative position let's say
that I'm not taking responsibility for
my life in any sense and I'm not bearing
any moral load and it turns out that not
only are you successful but you're
competent and good well then you're a
real enemy because you're a judge under
those circumstances right because it's
it's your goodness in some sense your
competence and your goodness that's
really showing me in a negative light
and instead of wanting to contend with
that and to see myself reflected badly
in your mirror then I'm going to make
the accusation that everything you've
done is merely a consequence of power
and and even deep more deeply I'm going
to criticize the idea of merit and
competence itself because that gets me
out of my self-loathing say well there's
none of that's real none of that merit
none of that confidence is real and none
of the failure that I'm experiencing is
a consequence of my own inaction yet
it's all someone and then saw someone
else's fault and then I get to be
justified in going after them as well
yeah so that's that's a nice thing one
became here they came Nabal story is I
mean it's explicit about this and this
is even buried in the text right that's
explicit I mean God specifically says to
Cain Tim shell right you have the
capacity to overcome yes right and that
and he goes in calais go yeah and that's
the whole idea that you know that's the
crux of that story is that because Cain
complains to God right says what he
basically says something along the lines
not fair what happened that's right how
dare you set up a universe like this
where I'm breaking myself in half
attempting to you know to thrive and
everything's going against me and I have
my brother who who everything that he
touches turns to gold and that's right
God says to him directly look to
yourself it's it's your inadequacy
that's driving this and it's the last
thing that Cain wants to hear and they
say that's what makes a murderer and I
think that that is the last thing that
most people want to hear that's what's
so attractive about a leftist ideology
that doesn't actually provide any sense
of meaning outside of the victimhood
cult this is this feeling that
the last thing that people want to hear
generally is look to your look to
yourself first it's a lot easier to mean
but it's also bad parenting right I mean
like but it's also funny because one of
the things that's happening in my
lectures is because I've been doing
something different you know instead of
saying see I think one of the things
that the conservative types do wrong
with regards to responsibility is that
they they they conceptualize it too
rigidly in terms of duty and should and
that that's a that's true but it's also
a mistake because what I've been
suggesting to people is that no you
don't understand is that all the meaning
in your life is going to come as a
consequence of accepting response yeah
it's not merely a matter of duty it's
that you need this sustaining meaning
because otherwise you you suffer
stupidly and you get bitter and you get
resentful and you get cruel and you get
homicidal and you get genocide that's
the whole pathway and so that's that's a
catastrophe that's hell and so if you
don't have something meaningful to
pursue to to set against that that's
that's your that's the degeneration of
nihilism okay so where do you find the
response where do you find the meaning
say well you look at people that you
admire and almost all the people you
admire are people who take on a heavy
burden of responsibility and if the
responsibility is associated with the
value hierarchy so you're trying to
pursue something of ultimate value so
that's the responsibility that gives you
meaning and so you can talk to people
about taking responsibility for their
inadequacy if you point out to them that
who they could be as much better than
who they are so that there's a
trajectory and so that the idea of
taking on responsibility even for their
own inadequacies and errors is all of a
sudden associated with hope and not with
only condemnation and that works and
that like when I lay out that line of
argument in the lectures and they've
seen this multiple times it's always the
case that the lecture halls go silent
yeah some people are absolutely riveted
on that idea and this is interesting I
didn't interview with Tucker Carlson who
I know is in here with you also and one
of the things that we talked about was
you know what people should do in dying
towns they're in areas where the
industry has left what should they do
they're experiencing difficulty and I
was saying that telling people that the
jobs are coming
back falsely is not going to actually do
anything for them that the the only
thing that you're guaranteed in America
or in a free country is the adventure
right that's what you're guaranteed and
that's also what makes life meaningful
is that sense of adventure that's what
America was built on right that's the
fundamental command the very first
command that Abraham has ever given is
get up leave the land of your father's
where it happened and go someplace yeah
where you I'm not gonna tell you where
you're going you're just gonna go there
and then when you get there maybe you'll
know right and that's and that's but I
think that one of the areas Jordan where
you and I I think it would be
interesting to drill down is when it
comes to directing toward the purpose
how do we define what the purpose is
because I think one of the things that's
been difficult in the West at least
since the death of the judeo-christian
value system in many ways or at least
the the sort of we're running on the
fumes of the judeo-christian value
system is but since the since the
decline of the importance in many
people's minds of that value system the
decline of biblical living has been this
idea you can create your own meaning
yeah right you just did that if you find
something that you truly care about and
then you pursue that thing that you
truly care about this will bring you
happiness and that may be true for a
certain number of people but the vast
majority of people are incredibly crappy
at coming up with their own meanings
yeah there has to be something that is
out there that is discoverable in order
for it to be I think that's what the
psychoanalysts that's why I like you so
much because that was that's what made
him such an astute critic of Nietzsche
because Nietzsche believed we had to
create her own values but the
psychoanalyst starting with Freud
started to note that the values were
actually built in and Freud saw that
first of all in dreams right and then
young too young took that apart and
associated the dreams with the myths and
said no no you don't understand is that
the values are built in you don't create
them you can rediscover them and that's
the resurrection of the father from from
from them from the ability of the Beast
the question is - and we you not
discussed this before is is where
exactly that moral system comes from so
conce
obviously talks about the idea that you
know he believes in God because of the
starry sky above and the moral law
within here you can you can discover all
this within I am not convinced that
human beings can actually discover
meaning within because if that were true
then the prosperity and liberalism and
human rights and value for individuals
and all the things that we associate
with the good stuff in the West that
would have been Universal and it is not
in fact universal it arose at a certain
time in a particularly
place associated with a particular value
system this is why when people ask me
about why I think the revelation is
necessary why it's important is because
I think that without you're gonna have
to make these fundamental assumptions to
get from point A to point B you're gonna
have to make fundamental assumptions at
point a now you can either get that from
Revelation or you can just assume it and
then try to explain where those
assumptions came from or you can just
pretend those assumptions don't exist
which is I think actually what what Sam
sort of does and I hate to criticize Sam
in his absence but I think that Sam sort
of just assumes that when he says things
like we're here for the greater
flourishing of human beings yeah you
actually have to define every one of
those terms they're a bunch of
assumptions baked into what all of that
means that he's making and I'm not sure
that Sam will acknowledge he's making
them but the that's why to me and this
is sort of thesis of my book next year
the the West is built on the the basic
revelations of Jerusalem meaning human
beings are made in God's image with
individual value and with individual
purpose and with a collective purpose
where we get together and we pursue
living in a more virtuous way and that's
one pole and the other pole is the
reason of Greece where we have the
capacity to look at the world around us
and draw conclusions from that world and
on those poles are built all of modern
science are built all of economics are
built the free speech and free and free
lives that we live right now and I think
that we have been gradually over the
last 200 years chipping away at both of
those poles Jerusalem in terms of
Revelation and Athens in terms of reason
which we have abandoned for
post-modernism is to deprive us of
purpose so in a weird way is this the
failure of the Enlightenment liberals
all the people that I grew up loving and
caring about and the people that I still
admire that and this this little sliver
of Liberals that still remain that
haven't bought into leftist dogma but
that aren't necessarily religious per se
or believe in these stories but really
they believe it comes from the
Enlightenment period I think I think
that's a good observation that this is
sort of their failure and only I don't
want to I'm not blaming it's their
arrogance I would say because even
people whose not enough to there's not
enough in your world to fight to fight
this new really know that's like that's
where I'm sort of finding myself right
now which is an incredibly uncomfortable
place I come from a much more atheist
perspective obviously than you and
certainly where you are
and yet I can see what the future is now
and it's like there's nothing left over
there and we do need some fundamentals
just the position without the mythos
underneath it exactly with winter where
I disagree with people like Steven pinky
I'm an Enlightenment guy but the thing
is is that when I look backwards in time
you know what what what people like
Harrison Pinker attribute to the
Enlightenment I see as the Enlightenment
being the latest flowering of a process
that was indescribably older than that
is exactly right I mean then in the and
in the historical Sam certainly grounded
in the religious traditions but and then
from my perspective grounded in
something that's biological that's far
deeper than that like like our true
proclivity towards admiration for
competence and reciprocity and I do
think that has to be socialized back to
your point so I wanted one of the things
Dave mentioned before we we started this
was that we could have a bit of a
conversation about the difference
between Judaism and Christianity and I
transferred I'd love to get that and you
want to make one comment on the neo
enlightenment stuff so I mean I will say
that there is a full chapter in my book
that is specifically about the views of
a lot of people who I love you know Sam
and Michael Shermer and then and and
Pinker and the whole neo enlightenment
strain of thought that I think kind of
includes general Goldberg on that
conservatives yeah and I love these guys
and I feel intellectually I feel more
comfortable with that position but I
realize I'm just being whittled away
so here's my basic view and my basic
thesis is that there are two views of
the Enlightenment one is that in general
Goldbergs words it was the miracle that
depends kind of sprang from nowhere
suddenly reason dominated over
revelation and it crushed revelation and
in the wake of that crushing came the
full flowering of economics and humanity
and freedom and liberalism and that
those things were opposed reason to
revelation exactly's were that these
were and not only that they weren't
intention they were fulsomely opposed
because there's truth that reason in
Revelation our intention but it is also
true that certain assumptions undergird
the assumptions of reason in order for
you to believe that reason exists and
isn't just a an evolutionarily favorable
firing of neurons then you have to if
you if you like I think that Sam's
position that objective
exists in the absence of anything
remotely approaching a system of
assumptions is unsupportable it's
completely unsupportable I think that I
think that because you're built to
create more little copies of you I mean
this is evolutionarily speaking what you
are created to do how that has to do
with discovering objective truth is not
only beyond me
so the in and what it has to do with the
existence of objective truth in any in
any case the enlightenment is based on
certain fundamental assumptions it's
based on the idea that you can act as an
individual freely by making rational
decisions in a predictable world of laws
right all every one of those assumptions
is ungrounded in in a world of pure
scientific determinism it just doesn't
it doesn't exist
so the educated self the layman ate
itself what happened is that the
Enlightenment the Enlightenment was and
I think that you see this in conscious
Kant seats all this he sees that this
struggle is coming and so he attempts to
reenact religion and spirituality and
God back into a moral system without
actually saying so Rane Khan says not
actually an atheist cons is actually
trying to create a rational basis for
Christian revelation and Christian
reasoning so that he can avoid the trap
of having to cite the Bible but he can
say that all of this makes sense anyway
well that's why I see this as the
failure of the modern liberals because
it's like even with some of some of our
IDW crew that most of these people most
of us come from the left originally and
it's like well the position we're right
now is there's no one on the left that
will talk to any of us without attacking
us or doing any of the usual tricks now
we've got all of these people like you
and Prager and the rest of them that are
willing to talk to us willing to debate
all you know all of this and I still see
a hesitancy because people it's so it's
so sort of built into people that
conservatives are evil or they even
thinking about the world through a
religious lens or anything like that is
somehow evil or dumb or something like
that and it's like I just can't play by
that well I think the the the
psychoanalysts and and some of the
neuroscientists that I knew - the ones
that were more informed about about
emotion and motivation and also
interested in dreams and instincts so
those would be the neuroscientists that
were concerned with emotion a rather
the cognitive types the cognitive types
are like the rationalists in the
psychology field they're very open to
the two they were surprisingly open to
Union ideas you know the idea that you
know our rationality is embedded inside
our emotions and that's all embedded
inside our motivations and that's all
embedded inside our bodies lie so
rationality isn't this this what would
you call it free-floating
soul in some sense that's capable of
contemplating the objective world but
something that's deeply embedded inside
all sorts of other structures on which
its validity is dependent one of the
things the psychoanalysts were so good
at pointing out and that I think is in
accordance with the neuropsychological
evidence is that your rationality is
bounded by the dream and it's literally
that way because if you are deprived of
dreaming which kind of puts you in the
mythic world then you go you literally
lose your mind there has to be that
continual dialogue between revelation
that would be associated with the dream
world and rationality or rationality
cannot sustain itself and the reason for
that is that as far as I can tell is
that the assumptions of rationality are
in the myth in the mythos which was the
argument that I was trying to make
continually with Sam and so then the
question is what constitutes the mythos
and so you one of your points was while
there's this idea that human beings are
made in the image of God and so I've
been thinking about that a lot and so my
sense is something like this is that and
you tell me what you think about this
okay so you wake up in the morning and
your consciousness emerges from nothing
in some sense and what you see in front
of you
you aren't determined like a clock in
what you're going to do that day in fact
your consciousness is in fact that part
of you that deals with what is not yet
determined because all the things that
you do that are fundamentally habitual
and deterministic are unconscious may
turn into habit and you don't have
conscious control over them so
consciousness seems to be that element
that deals with what has not yet been
determined okay so you wake up in the
morning and what you confront as far as
I'm concerned is potential there's a
there's a field of potential in front of
you and that that's the future whatever
that is that potential it's it's what
could be
and what is not yet and then as a
consequence of the choices that you make
guided by your ethical aims then you
transform that potential into actuality
and you literally do that with your
consciousness and I think that's the
reflection of the image of God in man
and I think that's what's put forward in
the earliest sections of Genesis because
that's what God does right God is a
structure he confronts nothingness with
with something approximating
consciousness the logos and he extracts
out order from potential and and then
one of the things that's interesting
about that there's there's repetition of
the idea in in Genesis that if you
confront potential with truth so that's
the logos let's say with truth then the
order that you produce is good so
there's a so which is a really
interesting ethical claim right you take
this potential you interact with it
morally the consequence of interacting
it morally is that you produce reality
and the reality that you produce is good
and then human beings are a microcosm of
that that does that see I know that
that's exactly right I mean I think that
this is the kind of philosophy in
philosophy terms this is basically the
argument but Maimonides and Thomas
Aquinas we're making this argument
basically at the same time is that you
know at the beginning when it says Bracy
Parral became at such a minor it's that
that in the beginning God created the
heavens and the earth what makes human
beings in the image of God is our
creative capacity and the creative
capacity is the ability to transform
through an act of will something that
was not into something that is and
that's what the beginning chapters of
Genesis are it's God taking things and
just making them and then what makes
them good is that these things are this
is the Aristotelian part is these that
these things are directed to our purpose
toward a purpose
so what the the idea of Greek
rationality what distinguishes it from
other ideas of rationality is that Greek
rationality is based on a fundamental
premise which is that you can look at a
thing and the thing was made for
something right so if you look at if you
look at a glass the glass was made to
hold liquid and you can tell that
because that's the nature of the glass
now there's nothing in science this is a
glass was made to hold liquid it's just
a piece of glass that is made in a
certain particular shape but we as human
beings know that this glass was made to
hold liquid and that we can look at the
universe in the same way that we can we
can say what was the purpose of this
thing
and that's why when God says that
something is good the use of the word
good in Aristotelian thought is good
it's fit for the purpose what makes you
a good pilot for example is your
capacity to land a plane what makes this
a good glass is its capacity to hold
liquid and what makes you a good person
is your capacity to use rationality in
pursuit of virtue and to transform the
world around you in doing so that's what
makes you a good person and so when it
says in the beginning of Genesis that
God has the tree of good and evil and
that you are the knowledge of good and
evil and it's a sin to eat from the
knowledge of good and evil my
understanding of that is that what human
beings did is instead of trying to
function according to figuring out what
God's purpose for things was trying to
figure out what the universe was to be
used for in accordance with reality we
decided to superimpose our own vision of
what reality should be in a moral sense
and that there's a fundamental
disconnect there and it leads to
suffering all right so let's let's dumb
this down for just one second because I
want to ask a question that I know you
don't like getting when we get in the
Q&A s but I think would be interesting
for the three of us to sort of kick it
around here which is for the average
person that that's listening to this
that can only take in so many of these
ideas and so much of this right and I
think that actually is most people that
are just living their lives I think a
certain set of people are listening to
both you and going alright these two
guys think that some guy is talking to
them from the sky I mean I know this is
this is the most I know why this mean
you don't love this question because
it's so ridiculously oversimplified but
how do you get to those people then for
the people that think we'll wait a
minute what do you what do you talk
about superior loves facts / feelings
but he's talking about this imaginary
sky guy that wrote this book and blah
blah blah what do you think is the is
there a psychological trick to sort of
get people over that hump if you wanted
them to start exploring some of this
well you know we can we can do the
high-level stuff for hours and hours but
but eventually it just keeps getting to
a sort of smaller and smaller place that
people can can get to all right so
that's so that's so hard to question and
so I'll try to address it this way so
there's a line in the New Testament
where Christ says that no one comes to
the Father except through him which is a
hell of a thing for anyone to say I mean
there's a lot of statements in the New
Testament that are strikingly strange
in that manner I am the way and the
truth and the life that's another one
it's associated with the same idea and
well to some of them so here's here's
the idea and it bears on your question
although I don't exactly know how it's
as if there's a spirit at the bottom of
things that is that is involved in the
in the in the bringing to being of
everything so like so for example people
talk about evolution as a random process
but that's not true it's not true the
mutations are random but there's also a
lot of sources other sources of genetic
variant variation but the selection
mechanisms are not random
so now then the question is what are the
selection mechanisms so I'm gonna have
to go a bunch of well here's one
selection mechanism it's like so human
females are very sexually selective
that's why you have twice as many female
ancestors as male ancestors so the male
failure rate for reproduction is twice
that of the females okay so the question
is well how is it that males succeed
differentially and the first answer is
well females reject if human females
reject but then the question might be
well they reject on the basis of what
and the answer is well it's something
like competence and then the question is
well how is confidence defined and then
the answer to that is well men put
themselves in hierarchies and they vote
on each other's competence and it's
really counterintuitive in some sense
from a evolutionary perspective because
you'd have to ask yourself why would men
put themselves in positions where they
elevate some men in status and then give
them a huge rep reductive advantage
given that that's to their reproductive
disadvantage in some sense ok and there
are reasons part of that might be let's
say you decide to follow the best leader
in a battle well then you don't die like
he might get all the women but you don't
die it so at least you're still in the
game and it might be the same if you're
following the greatest hunter and the
greatest hunter wouldn't be the person
who was best at bringing down the game
it would be the person who is best at
bringing down the game and sharing it
and organizing the next hunt and all of
that right and so men will organize
themselves into groups and privilege
certain men
that puts them ahead in the reproductive
hierarchy and so what that means to some
degree is that there's a spirit of
masculinity that's shaping the entire
structure of human evolutionary history
that's what that means
and then I think okay well that might
just be a biological epiphenomena and so
it would be a spirit that it's the
spirit of positive masculinity
that manifests itself across epochal
ages millions of years perhaps and it
actually has shaped our consciousness
actually and so you can think about that
as a figure and it would be the figure
that emerges it's like it's like the
it's like this it's like the essential
spirit of all the great men who defined
what greatness constituted that's a
spirit okay now that's a purely
biological explanation you could say
well that's gone for all intents and
purposes you might have an image of that
built right into you even the sense that
you can experience something divine and
paternal might be merely a reflection of
that evolutionary process so that would
be a biologically reductive argument for
the existence of what we experience as
God but then there's another possibility
too which is that that's actually
reflective of a deeper metaphysical
reality that has to do with the nature
of consciousness itself and I would say
that I think that's true is I believe
the biological case and I believe the
biologically reductive case but I don't
think that exhausts it I think that
there's a metaphysical layer underneath
that that the bile that the biology is a
genuine reflection of and that's the
sort of the macrocosm above in the
microcosm below that we that we are
really reflective including in our
consciousness of something about the
structure of reality itself and that
might involve whatever whatever it is
that God is what so that's why I think
this is so interesting because what
you're doing there especially at the end
is you're giving it a little room to say
I don't know right you have to yeah but
I think that that's what people don't
want to grant believe in God it's like
well that's like it's to me that
question is always like well what makes
you so sure that you know that God
exists it's like well I'm not sure I'm
not willing to claim that certainty you
know but well but I laid out argument so
what do you think about when he takes it
all the way
that and and then there's that little
space at the I mean again I don't think
that that's severely problematic in
terms of just general religious thought
I mean the general religious thought
going back thousands of years and this
is why when you look at Aquinas as
proofs of God what he comes to is he
says basically what you say which is if
you go down deep enough then you get to
something and that something is what we
call God so he doesn't say God he
doesn't the Bible starts from the
premise God exists and he created the
universe Aquinas starts from we have a
universe
what says God is there and he says when
you go all the way down deep enough
there has to be a force that lies behind
the combined logic of the universe and
that thing is what we call God right and
so he's trying to reason his way back to
first principles and I think that the
the case for God not in the way that we
think of him is like a jolly bearded guy
in the sky who like takes care of all of
our problems or anything but the idea
that there is a logos right this is that
there's a structure a fundamental
structure to the way life is and there
was a reason and the fundamental purpose
to why life is and what lies below that
you can call God and that without some
association with it well and that well
your consciousness reflects God again
this is the this is one of the
fundamental this is sort of live
anissa's proof of God is that the
principle of sufficient reason the idea
that you are capable of understanding
the universe if you actually believe
you're capable of understanding the
universe in any way in any way then your
mind has to in some if you believe in
objective reality as Sam does and you
believe that your mind is capable of
grasping an objective reality not an
evolutionarily beneficial reality but an
objective reality your mind is
reflecting a greater mind right your
mind is reflecting a greater logic well
what stands behind that greater logic it
must be something right and so this is
the idea that there is a god that stands
behind that so the proof for God I think
honestly is is not supremely difficult
and I think that we all do have whether
it's biologically sourced or in my view
logically sourced a belief that there is
a structure to the universe of
predictable structure to the universe
that didn't emerge out of simple
randomness and there's a reason that
things are the way that they are and
that from that we can draw the fact that
we are capable of acting within that
logical universe of everything or sheer
chaos you could not act you can realize
by the Kassadin surrounds you so would
you both argue then that at a micro
level and at the individual level you
could live a perfectly good
life with whatever morals subset you
create but that but that I think
ultimately you're both making the
argument that at a macro level a society
just can't can't can't function without
the mythos no you're embedded in that
and so well and I was talking about this
Christian idea too so so I've been
thinking about that statement about no
one comes to the Father except through
me and I thought okay but what does that
mean exactly and I've worked a lot of
this out over these lectures that you
know that you know I've been
participating in well so there is this
notion and that that height and lukanov
are also pursuing in in the coddling of
the American mind that you know one of
the ways that you in noble people and
encourage them is by having them
confront things that are frightening to
them that are beyond them so what do you
what you really want to do is you want
to optimally challenge people and what
that does is make them braver and
stronger not less afraid it makes them
more courageous and more competent okay
and I would say the clinical evidence
for that is overwhelming if you if you
pull a hundred educated clinicians and
use and you say to them well is there
utility and having people get their
ethical story straight and face the
things that they're avoiding they're all
going to say yes those are fundamental
fundamentally curative and this is quite
literally what we're doing the reverse
of that College yes exactly the reverse
okay so now here's the idea here's the
idea so imagine that you are in some
sense the embodiment of that paternal
spirit that has characterized mankind
since the dawn of time it's locked in
you it's part of your potential and
maybe that's coded that's coded at least
in part biologically but it's also coded
sociologically it's it's in the air so
to speak around you in the mythos and in
the stories we tell each other okay so
now what you decide to do and this is
this is where I think we could have an
interesting conversation about the
relationship between Judaism
Christianity so there's an idea in
Christianity which is I think the
central idea which is that you need to
face the potential for malevolence that
exists within you and in the world
so that's Christ's confrontation with
the devil in the desert with Satan in
the desert you have to come to terms
with that malevolence that's part of
existence and you have to voluntarily
accept the burden of suffering and so
that's the acceptance of
Krauss okay so you take on that you say
the suffering so there's an idea that
Christ is a messianic figure because he
took the suffering of the world onto
himself and what that means to me is
that he was someone speaking
conceptually who decided that the
suffering of the world was his
responsibility and that that's what
you're supposed to do you're supposed to
decide that that's your responsibility
you take that on as a burden you do the
same with the malevolence so when you
read history you read history as a
perpetrator right maybe you also read it
as a victim but you certainly read it as
a perpetrator and then that's on you
mm-hmm okay so then the question is what
happens when you do that and I would say
the answer is two things is that first
of all it starts to force you to develop
like to learn what you need to learn in
the world and to absorb the information
that would enable you to start to face
the suffering and to rectify it so that
forces you to become a more competent
person and that's the socialization part
that you thought of is so important but
then there's a secondary thing that
happens to which is that taking on that
additional stress and demand voluntarily
transforms you biologically because
within your genetic structure let's say
there's all sorts of potential but that
won't be unlocked unless you place
yourself in a position where the demands
necessitated and so by following that
pathway truth let's say the acceptance
of suffering and the confrontation with
malevolence so that's the heaviest load
that you could take on then you actually
produce a psychophysiological slash
spiritual transformation in yourself
that matures you into like the
representation of the father on earth
that's why that that's how that I'm glad
I'm glad he got us here because the
question that I said you there was only
one thing I said you guys were started
that I wanted to get to something about
most of the lectures that you when we're
doing these things you're usually
talking about the Old Testament now
obviously you're an Old Testament guy I
found a my my question was do you think
that Ben or just people that believe in
the Old Testament exclusively are
missing something so you just laid out a
case of something that potentially is
missing here do your argument well what
I'm going to argue is that what you just
said is
unchristian in the sense that you're
saying that everyone is supposed to
imitate Jesus and the basic conceit of
from what I understand speaking with
Christian theologians is that we are
fundamentally incapable of taking on our
own sin and so we have to have somebody
who comes in the form of Christ on earth
in order to accept that suffering for us
and that that is the purpose of God
actually embodying himself in Christ is
to provide human beings the capacity to
withdraw from original sin that we don't
actually have the capacity beyond a
certain point to overcome and that's why
Jesus as a singular figure is necessary
I actually agree from a Judaic point of
view with everything that you say
because for me it's about accepting
responsibility for my own sins on myself
and I don't have the ability to say that
there is the the suffering servant the
suffering Lamb of God who sacrificed
himself to relieve me of my sins and
therefore give me a fair shot at life
yeah well okay that's so that's a really
good objection I think and I think that
there's a fair bit of confusion about
that in the Christian community for
example so I would say that that
perspective is more explicitly
Protestant and then then I would put the
Catholics next to that but then I would
put the Orthodox types fairly far away
from that which is why so many Orthodox
Christians I think have been interested
in what I'm saying because their sense
and this is where my knowledge of
Christian theology starts to run out
because of like I'm not an expert on you
know in the in the doctrinal differences
right their sense is that it's the
imitation that's of primary importance
now it's a weird thing because even in
classical Christianity you have let's
say Protestant Christianity you have
this idea that well Christ died to save
us all from our sins and so we're
already redeemed but that doesn't
alleviate the moral burden weirdly
enough because you'd think it should so
there's this paradox and I think it's I
I think part of the reason for that this
is this is an extraordinarily
complicated thing but in in in the
brothers karamasoff Christ comes back to
earth right and in Seville during the
Spanish Inquisition and so he's doing
his miracles and raising people from the
dead and like being all messianic and
the first thing that happens is the
Inquisitor arrests right throws him in
prison and then comes to visit them and
basically says look the last thing we
need after setting up this church
for 2,000 years is you you're a lot of
trouble you've put a moral burden on
human beings that's too much for them to
bear and so what we've done is watered
it down and put some intermediaries in
place so that the moral demand that your
example required doesn't just crush
people into nothingness
right so every ideal is a judge right so
then you have the ultimate ideal that's
the Altima judge and from the
inquisitors point of view that judge was
too much it was too demanding and so I
think there's an and so so anyway so the
Inquisitor goes through all this
argument says we're gonna have to you
know get rid of you again because you're
just too much to bear
and so Christ listens and doesn't says
and it doesn't say anything and then
just when the Inquisitor stands to leave
Christ kisses him on the lips and when
quiz' turns white in shock and then
leaves but he leaves the door open and
that's the brilliant that's the
brilliant ending of of Dostoyevsky's
yeah and what makes him such a genius
because he basically says something like
well look that the Catholic Church did
reduce the burden and it is corrupt in
the way that earthly organizations are
likely to be corrupt and it does allow
an out which is why you can put your
sins on Christ let's say and that
alleviates your moral burden but it
still keeps the damn door open well it's
nuts so this is why I think it's really
fascinating having having spent a lot of
time with Christian theologians in the
past couple of years writing this book
is that the the original conceit I think
when when when you talk with people who
are Christian and Jewish and you have
sort of interfaith conversations the
original one sentence can see the
difference between them is that what you
hear from Jews is Judaism Zak's based
and Christianity is faith based
Christianity is about the acceptance of
Christ when you accept Christ then
you've accepted what you need to accept
and everything flows therefrom and
Judaism says it's not just about
accepting God it's all these Mitzvah
right there are all these commandments
that you have to do and these are what
perfects you as a human being it's the
performance of these Commandments
accepting God's sovereignty because he's
the one who gave the commandments but
you actually have to act in the world
and if you don't act in the world then
you haven't fulfilled your
responsibility in the world this could
also be an argument why you could have
although I know you wouldn't be throw
the yapper say you could have Jewish
atheists and that they believe that it's
just their actions here
yes a 100% so this is why you know Jews
have had very and I think most
Christians believe this too the idea of
having a moral atheist is not really a
difficult idea yeah it's the idea of
having a system built on atheism that's
completely immoral and will fall apart
almost immediately and the idea of
having a moral system built on atheism
if you examine your atheism closely
enough
I think falls apart I think that moral
atheism is basically you separating your
morality from your atheism and then
ignoring your atheism in pursuit of the
morality which is well you can live fine
that way that's fine but I don't think
that that's psychologically sustainable
and if you actually examine the core of
your ideas but with that said I think
that Christianity after its original
mullen Aryan viewpoint when when
Christianity first came about the idea
of Christ on earth was that he had
ushered in the Messianic era because
this was it was it was a new era it was
a new day and then it turns out that
people looked around the way well this
looks a lot like the old day right now
not that much has changed and so what
changed what changed was our spiritual
status that was the new redefinition of
the Messianic era is that the the what
Christ had brought to Earth was a new
spirit right he'd brought a new spirit
into the earth and he he'd cleansed
people of their sins and given them a
fresh shot at life basic yeah and that
in doing so he changed the nature of how
things work well Judaism basically said
well we never thought that that nature
changed in the first place right that's
that's that's something different
and so ironically enough I think one of
the sources of Christian anti-semitism
over time is an attempt to distinguish
what makes Christianity different from
Judaism other than Christ because
Christianity and Judaism in most of
their main philosophies have an awful
lot in common it's interesting I just
interviewed a fellow named John
MacArthur who's a major pastor major
Christian theologian I interviewed him a
couple of days ago for our Sunday
special and this came up I asked him so
where do you think the differences are
between Christianity and Judaism and he
basically said Jesus right that's the
difference and I think that that is the
mostly honest answer because when I hear
Christian theologians try to distinguish
Judaism from Christianity what they say
about Judaism I find to be not accurate
as to what Judaism actually says and
when I hear Jews try to distinguish
Christianity from Judaism I think that
well and I'm not saying they're the same
thing because they're not obviously
they're different belief systems but in
terms of the underlying value system
there
we say judeo-christian value system is
because in terms of the value system
itself the commonalities are
overwhelming they're overwhelming the
differences are mostly doctrinal and
historical and in terms of what you
think III think the Christians read back
in an acts based version of their own
lives through a variety of mechanisms
whether they say well predestination
exists but in order to show that if I
really elect I would be acting this way
right that is an acts based version it's
just retroactive from the end and so
this is why if you say to a Christian so
you really believe that you can lead a
terribly dissolute awful terrible life
but if you believe in Christ with the
full fiber of your being you're going to
heaven and they'll say and many of them
will say yes but then you say but what
makes a good person and they'll say
right not but if but they'll always have
but if you believe in Christ you
wouldn't do all those things well that's
that's the thing well not and that's why
people are always criticizing me when I
give an answer to the question that you
dis ask because my my answer has been
well I act as if God exists well that's
kind of weaselly it's like no it's not
because it gets to the to the core of
this what do you mean by believe well do
you believe in Christ well does that
mean you enter the words that he existed
well that's a pretty shallow form of
belief in fact I think that's no form of
belief at all in fact it says in the New
Testament Christ Himself says is
something along the lines of not all
those who utter the words Lord Lord will
be saved
right and so and Nietzsche's criticism
of Christianity doctrinal Christianity
was basically based on the idea that
Christianity had taken the easy route
out by insisting upon the statement of
faith rather than the embodiment of the
belief in action which would be the
imitation of Christ by the way is Jesus
original criticism of Judaism right is
that everybody takes the the
commandments extraordinary seriously
they don't take the spirit of the
commandments ooh yes exactly that's
right that's exactly right it is the
same it's the same thing and so you know
Nene Chia's criticism of Christianity
was that there were very few real
Christians because they didn't take on
the burden of the action and I would say
it's the belief is actually manifested
in the burden of the action now you
might want to say you might want to be
in a position if you were Christian to
say well my explicit statements of
belief match what I act out because
maybe there'd be a unity in that but the
fundamental issue is
what you is what the belief is
manifested in what you do because that's
what you stake for me belief is what you
stake your life on that's belief and you
stake your life on what you act out and
so you're trying to act out the idea
that well that you take I think that you
take on the suffering of the world and
the malevolence of the world as your
responsibility you know what's really
fascinating is I think that what this
comes down to a lot of this debate comes
down to which from which end you're
teaching I think that it's almost two
sides of one coin and if you're talking
to a bunch of people who are not
religious who don't believe in the Bible
right you're talking to an adult who
looks at the Bible it says I don't
believe all of these ridiculous miracles
happen why should I bother engaging why
should I believe all this stuff and my
argument has always been because you do
believe all this stuff you're just
pretending that you don't in the sense
that you don't care about the historical
circumstance but all the things that
you're acting out in daily life I said
this to Sam right on stage is is that
you know you and I hold ninety-five
percent the same values where do you
think those came from and Sam said well
you know I've done a lot of studying a
lot very okay but that doesn't explain
why you and I hold ninety-five percent
of the same values could I have known
any of those things but I didn't spend
any time studying the the philosophies
of the east the reason we hold
ninety-five percent the same values cuz
you grew up in a judeo-christian
civilization with 3,000 years of common
history that's why we share the same
value system you need mushrooms and on a
river in Brazil exactly and somehow we
end up in pretty much the same place
about what we think is actually
important in life and which liberties
are important in all this stuff and we
have disagreements around the edges but
this is the West right this is the West
is different it is not the same as other
philosophies and so what I'm talking to
people about that the case that I'm
making is you are part of this great
river of history you can pretend you're
not part of that great river you can
pretend you're not living off the fumes
of that River you are a living ouu you
can pretend that the gas tank is running
on its own it ain't okay you there's a
there's a deposit of fuel so you're
still living off that that's but and but
that is a different thing than what you
teach a child and this is where I think
that that things become different
because I think that your philosophy
Jordan is self-sustaining to a group of
people who are looking at the values
they live and saying where did these
come from and how do I justify these
values but I think that would be very
difficult to teach child values before
you teach the myth so I think that
you're coming at people and saying to
them your values can be justified by the
myth
yeah but when you're teaching a child
values it's a myth you have to teach
your have to keep teaching the kids the
story first of course and then come the
values yeah so the and so there's a
difference between this is we won't even
listen unless you teach the story
nationally and this is why as a
religious person I teach my kids the
stories first because the values are
embedded in the stories and what I do I
have questions about the stories what
rational person wouldn't have questions
about the stories of course you have
questions about the reality or the
historicity of the stories that doesn't
undercut number one the importance of
the stories and number two the point is
that you have to believe the fundamental
assumptions embedded in the stories
whether or in order for the values to
North knowing society that's exactly why
you said before that the Enlightenment
couldn't have just sprung out of nothing
right I mean that's that's exactly what
you were saying that it needed all of
the bedrock well I would think that for
people who are fundamental evolutionary
biologists and I kept trying to make
this case to well you can make a case
like that to Pinker and the psychologist
but also the Harris it's like what do
you get where do you guys get off
thinking that this is a consequence of
the last 300 400 years right it's like
we're looking at time spans even the
Enlightenment figures they lived in a
world that was like 6,000 years old
we're living in a world that's three and
a half billion years old you have to
extend your thinking about the origins
of phenomena like like morality way past
way back past the Enlightenment and so
this adventure thing this is a good
example of of the wisdom that's embedded
in those myths so like I didn't know and
I will say sorry to just pause for a
second and I would say in that history
specifically because as a point to
believe I do believe that this is a
historical circumstance and whether you
call it myth or history as long as you
believe the reality of myth and you and
I believe in reality in different ways
and this is part of the fundamental
distinction because my understanding is
that your understanding of what is true
and what is real is an almost a quasi
utilitarian Charles Purse view of
because you recommended me two books but
my my view is much more like Sam's in
the sense that most religious people
believe the objective truth about
historical myth yeah but when it comes
to getting beyond that question then I
think we're well complete what the
strange thing is to with these
mythological stories is that like there
are forms of abstraction that are more
true than than what they're abstracted
from right my mathematics is like that
and I'm going
to do a bunch of lectures on Exodus and
I think the mosaic story is a really
interesting example of that is like what
a good piece of here's a kind of truth
this is literary truth and it's true is
that well this happened and this
happened and this happened and this
happened and there was a pattern about
what happened let's call that the heroic
pattern for lack of a better word and so
the question is well what's the reality
is the reality the specifics of what
happened but in each person's individual
life or is it the general pattern that
manifested itself across all those
people and I would say if you want to
extract out guidelines for proper living
then the reality is the abstraction
that's that's that's pulled out of the
multiple stories and so even if the
story of Moses is a composite story in
some sense that doesn't mean it's not
true it's true the way and this is
something that that I could never make
headway with with regards to Sam it's
like well is there literary truth well
there better be because otherwise what
is the use of literature and how do you
rank order literature in terms of
quality if there's no standard of truth
well what's the truth well it's an
abstraction and if you don't think that
abstractions are true then you're not
thinking because you can easily make a
case that a proper abstraction is more
real than the thing from which it's
abstracted you certainly make that case
with mathematics and so these stories
it's not only that they have pragmatic
utility although I try to explain things
biologically when I can do that it's
that that utility is true in the broader
sense that we've been describing truth
and so this the Abrahamic story with the
call to adventure is very interesting so
and it's something else that I've been
lecturing to my audiences about it's
well what's the purpose of life well
it's an adventure well where do you see
that well you see that in the Abrahamic
story in particular cuz Abraham's this
guy whose fate who fails to launch right
he's 80 and he's still in his father's
intent and God says you know me
well and that's the call right what is
that you think well there's a call to
adventure while there is a call to
adventure young men die without that
call to adventure that's what attracts
them to Isis for God's sake is the call
to adventure right indeed and and you
could say well that's warped and twisted
in those individuals because the society
hasn't cat
canalize that into the proper channels
right it hasn't given them a moral
equivalent to war in William James terms
it hasn't called them out properly but
God calls out Abraham and all that
happens to Abraham to begin with is that
he encounters a famine and a tyranny and
a conspiracy to steal his wife like it's
a bloody pastor fee and you think oh I
see well it isn't that God is calling
you out to happiness he's calling you
out to the great adventure of your life
right and that comes along with the
suffering and the burden and the
malevolence and all of that and so it's
something grand and Noble like a like a
seafaring expedition on the high seas
it's not it's not that impulsive self
gratifying immediate happiness that
seems to be what would you say the
obsession of our current culture so it's
a call to to call the physical adventure
that I think people are lacking right
now but I think it's also called a
spiritual adventure in the sense that
you are supposed to see how your values
stack up against reality I mean this is
the the most famous story of Abraham I
said well the most famous story is that
is the sacrifice of Isaac and in that
story my view of that story is that I've
never found that story particularly
puzzling a lot of people find that story
particularly puzzling because it's God
saying you know go sacrifice your son
but to me what he's actually saying is
the fundamental truth that story is the
fundamental truth of raising a child and
committing to something because what God
is actually saying to Abraham is you
have to put your child at risk of death
to live for a certain set of values and
then Abraham has another has enough
faith to say and I trust that God is not
actually gonna kill my child but by
committing to this set of values I am in
fact when you might now there is no
Cruisers with your child in the world
yes that's right not only that you're
doing so on behalf of your family you're
doing so on behalf of the of your God
you're doing so on behalf of a broader
purpose and by the way this is what it
means to be I think a nemesis a fighter
and a soldier and an emissary for the
West I think this is true particularly
you know as a Jew I think there's always
been true of Jews because here's the
reality every time I see some my son is
born eight days later we circumcise him
we take a baby and we pre-commit him and
we say this is going to be your life now
your life is I am pre committing you
this is me doing you know what Abraham
did Isaac I am putting my child in more
danger by circumcising him and make
I'm a Jew than I would otherwise be
because Jews are a lot more danger in
the in the world than other people and
and but that's the point is that I'm
saying to my child I pre commit you to
this struggle I pre commit you to the
set of values and that does put you at
additional risk but that's also what
gives you meaning and throughout Jewish
history sometimes God doesn't find the
ram in the thicket right sometimes there
is no ram in the thicket sometimes the
kids die all right okay that is it that
is the reality of life and it's also the
reality of committing to any value
system worth committing it's so
interesting cuz I don't know that I've
heard you talk about this in the
lectures this specific issue through the
biblical lens but this is so consistent
with everything else you talk about
about how to be a good parent that
you've got to let them well you sir
deign well you you when you were when
you were talking about that the image
that came to my mind was Michelangelo's
pietà because what happens with Mary is
that she has foreknowledge that her son
will be broken by the world and yet she
offers she offers him up to the world
and then you think well if if a parent
is doing this in a moral manner then you
are offering up your children to be
broken by the world in the service of
God that's a sacrifice to go on and if
your the proper parent then you do
sacrifice you do sacrifice your children
to God because what you want from them
for them is to serve the highest
possible value if you love them that's
what you want and and that's a mortal
burden for them and well that's perfect
perfectly Illustrated because I think
that of the payout as the sort of the
female equivalent of the crucifixion mmm
right because of course Mary is is
integrity bound up with her son and yet
and he's broken sort of at the peak of
his power and beauty all of that and she
has to accept that as part of the
precondition of proper existence and so
there's a real sacrificial element there
and that is reflected in that story and
so and and and it's in its and it's
correct in that manner and it's a very
rough story so by teaching your children
values is in effect sacrificing to the
world in a way that they wouldn't if you
weren't teaching them the values but
it's also what allows them to live a
fulfilling life in doing that in pre
committing your child to values this is
one of the major problems that I have
with the way that the left has has
rewritten parenting this idea of
parenting is that you're just supposed
to let your kid rush out
the world without any preparation at all
without any pre-committed set of values
and discover the world on their own
without anything now it's one thing to
say you should encounter danger it's
another thing to make everything
inherently more dangerous by not
preparing your child for the possibility
of a world that requires values and
meaning well I know we saw this at hand
in Sweden where we were we weren't sure
why there was so much support for
everything you're doing in Sweden and
when the we do this QA after where
people are submitting questions you know
online and then I looked through him as
Jordans doing his talking that we answer
questions and 90% of the questions had
to do with gender issues and a ton of
them were about genderless kindergartens
and the emasculation of the father and
all of this stuff and it's like that's
exactly what you're saying and give
these kids well it's also it's also
extremely interesting following up on
your line of reasoning that well let's
say you do decide well I'm gonna launch
my children out into the world to let
them discover everything by themselves
well so what happens is well the world
becomes so terrifying that you have to
protect them from everything because
they don't have any they don't have any
autonomy they don't have exactly they
don't have any discipline they don't
have any inbuilt values all of that and
so the the counter consequence of that
maximal freedom and I've seen this with
people they have two-year-old kids and
they put no restraints on them
whatsoever they haven't taught the kid
what no means like and you can teach a
kid what no means very rapidly so if you
have a child that's learning to crawl
for example and you know maybe they're
gonna go pull something heavy on the
shelf all you have to do is grab them by
the leg and hold them and and say no
over and over until they stop doing what
they're doing and they'll usually cry
and so you know that's cruel okay so you
stop them and then if you do that for a
week then all you have to do is say no
and they'll cry and stop and then two
weeks later they won't cry they'll just
stop now no is a big deal
right because no is the imposition of
the patriarchy against that against that
instinctive explore another savage yeah
that's right against the noble savage
right so it's a big deal no so but then
ok but then now once your child has got
that you can leave them be because they
can explore like mad yeah the first
first of all you can stop them by saying
no and so that's really helpful because
if they're gonna do something dangerous
a word will do it but second kids are
really smart and what I learned with my
kids was once you talked
that there were five things in the house
they couldn't do then they generalized
from that and they figured out the
pattern of the things they couldn't do
and then they wouldn't do them and then
you could leave them alone they could be
autonomous and then parents would come
over who didn't teach their kids no and
they would follow their two-year-old
around like totalitarians 100% of the
time because they couldn't trust them to
have any autonomy at all yep
so the consequence of that absolute lack
of discipline is the necessity for
constant supervision and this is it's
it's also one of the reasons why I have
so much trouble with the way they're
speaking of the genderless parenting
aspect it's one of the reasons I have so
much trouble with all of this this idea
that kids that everything is
biologically pre-written and
biologically determined and that how you
raise your children has no impact on how
their future life goes is such asinine
[ __ ] I mean I'm sorry to put it that
way but it just is I have two kids under
five it is absolute nonsense so I told
the story the other day on the radio or
on my show on the podcast about my son
so my son is two and a half years old
and he is just a delightful human being
which means that if you were an adult
he'd be the worst person because it
because two-year-olds are savages this
is what they are anybody who tells you
that children are naturally good is
totally full of it children are
naturally innocent children are
naturally not good
children are naturally selfish and mean
and brutal to each other and then
they're joyous and then they're moved
joy right this is what they are and so
my son well he has an older sister and
his older sister loves sparkly things
it's just her thing she's she's a girl
and she's very girly and so she has all
these sparkly shoes lying around and so
my son decided that he wanted to go and
put on his sister sparkly shoes and I
went to him and I said no but those are
girl shoes oh I said no those are girl
shoes we don't wear those and he said
and he started to fuss he said no hey he
said I want I want Lee I want my monster
name I want her shoes I want her shoes
and I said those are girl things and
then I took him to the out of the
Western Outfitters over here and then
eyes and I got him a pair of cowboy
boots and he will not take off his
cowboy boots now the way the left would
see that is that is me cruelly crushing
his spirit perhaps he just wants to be a
girl perhaps he wants to be raised in an
effeminate manner yeah except that by me
at giving him the choice by going and
getting him cowboy boots and then saying
here here's some cowboy boots and
there's more gender
it turns out that that's what he likes
and you know what even if he didn't like
that
he's two-and-a-half years old you might
decide for him um out of hate that I'm
gonna get just for sitting here
listening to you tell that story of how
you parent didn't butch back on Shapiro
who didn't want his son to wear sparkly
shoes Robin he's not an adult when he's
17 if he makes a in affirmative case why
he should wear sparkly shoes go for it
yeah when he's two and a half I'm the
guy who gets to instill the system that
I think will lead to his greatest
happiness I am the totalitarian in my
own house I am the king of my own house
and I get to determine whether I think
my child will live a happier life
struggling with the desire to wear
sparkly shoes at age 25 or whether it
might be better for him to be brought up
in a situation where it's easier to
choose in line with gender stereotyping
that by the way is reflected over every
human culture the idea that gender
stereotyping is unique to the West is
absolute nonsense
there are differentiations between how a
treatment and how we treat women in
every culture in the history of humanity
yeah well that again is why the Sweden
thing was yeah well I mean because we
found out basically as you laid out and
feel free to clean this up was that
they've done egalitarianism right men
and women have been equal for quite some
time and yet still what has happened
there is that more men are engineers and
more women or nurses yeah men and women
are more different they're still
different yeah more Dvorak's yeah that's
right and yet the social justice
warriors or whatever this thing is they
won't let them have the win so they
really experiment well the other the
other issue here too is well imagine
that just hypothetically imagine that
you were going to try to raise your
children gender-neutral okay so there
was actually studies done on this back
thirty years ago where they looked at
self professed feminist parents and self
professed non feminist president parents
and then coded their interactions
blindly for gender stereotypical
behavior and found no difference between
the two groups well and the reason for
that is you know you think that you
socialize your children entirely if
you're a social constructionist it's all
top-down right because your child's a
blank slate but your child isn't your
child is manifesting to a greater or
lesser degree all sorts of gendered
behaviors and powerfully and a lot of
what you're doing especially if you're a
good parent is you're reacting to what
your child is manifesting as an
individual and so a lot of the
socialization
that so-called the socialization which
sounds like top-down is actually the
establishment of an of a singular
relationship between you as the parent
and that individual child with their
nature and this is this is also
reflected in the behavioral genetics
literature because what you see is that
imagine there's three sources of
variation in children's behavior there's
biological their shared environment so
this would be the sibling so this would
be what was the same in the family for
the siblings and then what was different
and then you look at the behavioral
outcome and you calculate how much was
biological how much was shared
environment and how much was non-shared
environment what you find is it's almost
all biology and non-shared environment
and so people have read that to say well
parents don't matter because there's no
shared environment but it's not the case
because what happens is if you're a good
parent is the relationship you have with
child one is significantly different
than the relationship with child - even
though there may be moral presumptions
that are organizing your families when
you're feeding your children identically
are almost never right all right never
that's Rwanda became enable right I mean
but that's it yes right I mean like if
God is the parent figure in that story
treating your children differentially is
a way of being a good parent your kids
exactly the same you're not being
responsive to your kids and you are
teaching them that that essentially
there are no consequences to actions
because your change right no matter what
it's the same outcome well that's yes
the parenting right no no that no that's
so that's almost the definition of
totalitarian parenting and it is exactly
the kind of relationship that you don't
want to have with anyone right you want
all of your relationships to be
individualized and particularized and so
and so and so the so we radically
underestimate the degree to which the
gendered interactions between children
and parents are driven by the children
so here's a funny experiment there's
some evidence that parents who drink
more are more likely to have children
with ADHD now I'm not a big fan of ADHD
diagnosis but we'll leave that aside
okay so so then there was some
suggestion that maybe well ADHD as part
of genetic complex that involves
alcoholism and antisocial personality
because those things also clump together
and so there's various experiments done
to see if that is the case and there
a fair bit of diagnostic overlap between
childhood conduct disorder and ADHD so
it's kind of messy irrelevant here's the
experiment they bring parents in to
interact with children who aren't their
own and you you have them do an alcohol
taste test and so the taste test is well
here's rum and coke and here's vodka and
orange juice and here's orange juice and
here's water and what we want you to do
is to just rate the taste of each of
these beverages okay and so then we
expose you to some children and one of
the children is a child with a diagnosis
of ADHD and one of the child children is
one that doesn't and then so you do that
with a bunch of parents and then you
have them do the taste test okay well
you don't care what they rate the damage
drinks you just care how much they drink
parents that were exposed to the kids
that have attention deficits so but
that's a good it's a good example of the
idea of by directionality and
socialization it's like you're not you
have a relationship with your child now
you obviously enforce a certain degree
of social norm if you're sensible
because you want your child to be
socialized and desirable to other people
you want them to be able to play
reciprocally and you want them to be
attentive enough to adults so that
adults treat them well so the world
opens up to them right so that's what
you're doing but other than that your
particular izing like mad because even
to get that child to that end state
requires a particular eyes path you know
my daughter was intrinsically very
cooperative and my son was intrinsically
very competitive and so the pathway to
getting them both to be reciprocal
players was substantially different even
though the desired out and they became
reciprocal players like they you know
they were part they were popular kids
who were in constant demand as playmates
which i think is the hallmark of
successful parenting by the way by the
time if your kids are four and other
kids really want to play with them it's
like you did it you got it right and if
they're not then something's gone
seriously wrong but there's multiple
pathways to that so I'm glad we got this
to the current day because one of the
things that I wanted to ask you guys
about is what we're basically talking
about here is living life with a certain
set of rules
we can whittle away whatever well though
I hear there's gonna be a couple there
is more coming that's the rumor that 12
whatever but we it seems to me we live
in a time where where the energy is just
around the people that have no rules so
you know sort of as the Trump thing grew
it was this sort of destructive force
you know that break all the things right
and Eric and I talked about how Eric
would have wanted
Eric Weinstein would have wanted a
panther in a china shop but I said you
just don't get that you get the bull in
the jaw that's how now I see the energy
behind sort of SJW left and and the news
that socialism is cool let and that it's
much easier to destroy them create do
you think that the rules that you lay
out in your book and the rules that you
talk about from a biblical perspective
and everything else that people with
rules can sort of survive in a crazy
time like we're in now where information
travels that much faster and there's
that much sort of entropy behind chaos
that maybe there wasn't before because
we couldn't transmit information so
quickly do you think there's enough
juice behind me I'm at disagree slightly
with the premise here Justin I don't
actually think that the left doesn't
have rules I think they have more rules
than we do I think that we have a
certain basic set of rules and then an
immense amount of freedom within these
guardrails I think the left in getting
rid of the guardrails head to because
human beings cannot live without rules
the left different really important
point they reversed engineered a set of
extraordinarily complex rules that are
arbitrarily applied so you don't even
know you violated a rule until after you
tripped over the rule right no favorite
place rules with taboos right exactly
exactly and and that is extraordinarily
dangerous so that the energy is behind
seeking a new set of rules the question
is can we defend our rules in such a way
that it is attractive to people that I
think you do that fundamentally by
pointing out the relationship between
rules and aspiration it's like the rules
define a value hierarchy and then that
gives you something noble to do that's
your call to adventure exactly and so
the rules don't constrain they do
constrain you obviously ranks
constrained but at the same time they
constrain they provide an organizing
framework and a direction and that's an
uni and and that
that direction isn't optional because
the other thing I know rules aren't like
pants okay you put them on and they're
fundamentally constraining but they
allow you to walk through right well
that's well that's also why when you see
that one of the first things that
happens in the Garden of Eden when Adam
and Eve become self-conscious as they
put on clothes exactly right it's a
constraint down to protection at the
same time and culture is always that
it's constraint and protection at the
same time and then the radical types are
always going oh you know oh the
constraint or the constraint and fair
enough right because there's that
tyrannical aspect but the protection and
the aspiration are of absolutely
critical importance and I don't think
there is a more I don't think that we've
laid out anywhere a more noble
orientation with regards to disciplined
aspiration then that that's encoded
inside the judeo-christian ethic and
that that is the core of the
Enlightenment and that is right okay
so another question about Judy is okay
sure okay so one of the things that I
would that I've always wondered about is
I think one of the things that
distinguishes Christianity from Judaism
is that Judaism has an implicit emphasis
on the Salvation on the cell on the
salvific properties of the state and I
don't think you see that in Christianity
to the same degree so I mean because
there's explain that well there well
there's not there's the idea of Israel
as part of it and there's the idea of
the Jewish nation as a people right
whereas Christianity has this
universalism right is it built into it
this is right right and so this is a
fundamental distinction okay so okay so
so and this is I've never been able to
have this conversation with anyone
because it's an unbelievably dangerous
conversation but it seems to me that it
seems to me that the advantage of
Christianity is that it places the
fundamental locale for salvation within
the individual I mean independently and
whether it's like pushed off for reasons
of mercy on to Christ right which is
something else we didn't finish
discussing is one of Jung's points with
regards to Christianity and Catholicism
was that there was a merciful element to
it because the burden that was placed on
each person being the locus of
redemption let's say was so heavy that
it was unbearable right and so that you
needed
intermediary structure to like lift the
load off you from time to time which is
what the Catholics do it's like well
here's all the ways that I've failed
that's okay
you're fallible you're a fallible human
being you don't have to be crushed into
absolute dust by the fact that you're
not everything you should be so all
right but anyways I think that's where
Jewish guilt kicks in if I'm not well
and it's also I think to some degree
where Protestant guilt kicks in because
the Catholics have that out right and
you can be cynical about that right say
well you send your whole life and then
on your deathbed you're converted it's
like well that's all nonsense because
you actually have to repent and so if
you have a lifetime of sin there's you
can see the mercy in that in that
Catholic approach because it gives you
like a reset in some sense right you get
to be washed the fact that you're not
everything you could be is a terrible
burden right and if you're carrying that
all the time it can just crush you into
that and that's and obviously that's
that's present in its earlier iteration
in the in the sacrificial system and the
temple among Jews or among the family
like I say in 3 times a day you say a
portion in the Shmona in the silent
prayer in which you repent your sins and
then we have a full day right Yom Kippur
is deliberately designed to do that and
to try and wipe the slate clean and as
far as the the other question that
you're a individual right so it to me
it's less about the state per se because
when you talk about the nation of Israel
I'm Easter Island the in the actual
biblical parlance it's not talking about
like a bordered state and incorporate
salvation within that it's about the
special responsibility of this group of
people to to spread like to the world
right that you're supposed to be in the
again Hebrew phrase when you lose a lot
of Hebrew today but we're talking Bible
so okay is that you're supposed to be a
malefic Kohanim vacatio she's meaning
that you're supposed to be a nation of
priests and a holy nation and so that
idea was expanded by Christianity to all
of Kim all of humanity corporately that
basically right this applies equally to
all humans now what's interesting about
Judaism is that Judaism actually has
almost a two-track approach so if you
are a Jew then you have these
responsibilities these 613 mitzvot you
are not barred from the afterlife or
from decency if you're not a Jew so
Judaism is only half exclusive
in the sense that if you're a junior Jew
and if you're not a Jew we try and
actually dissuade you from becoming one
but if you are a but if you are outside
the Jewish nation you have a share in
the afterlife so long as you fulfill
seven basic commandments the
commandments of Noah right so there's a
set of seven commandments that were
given to Noah these are basic basic
things don't steal don't murder don't
commit adultery don't eat the flesh of a
living animal don't you have to create
Courts of Justice these are like all
very very basic laws and so what that
means is that Judaism posits that your
Mazzoni is really interesting
philosopher from Israel he has a new
book out called the case for national oh
yes yeah it's really it's really
interesting in basically the case that
he makes is that the biblical Jewish
view of where values should be embedded
at the maximal level is a safer view
than the Universalist conception because
the Universalist conception that you
have a set of values that applies
equally to everyone across all times and
cultures actually leads to tyranny and
cram downs meaning that his argument is
that the threat of the 20th century was
not a bunch of nationalisms that were
embedding particular values it was
certain nationalism that want to become
universal isms it was Germany wanting to
be the right that ruled the entire world
where the USSR wanting to be a country
that was able to apply communism across
all times in all places so a certain
level of particularism in how we apply
basic rules the seven laws of Noah in
the biblical case or the Ten
Commandments you can have certain
cultural differentiations and that
allows for group cohesion and in a way
that you can't with the great mass of
humanity power of Babel problem you
expand the if you expand the dis example
to be too large then it starts to become
too complex and they structure into
totalitarian exactly so the Jewish
critique of the universalistic principle
would be yes there are certain
fundamental universal principles that we
should all hold by and those we hold
have to get by Jews and non-jews alike
but how those are iterated they have to
be iterated within a specific cultural
structure otherwise what you end up with
is people trying to cram down cultural
hallmarks of those structures on
everybody else and totalitarianism
springs from the idea that I'm going to
take my culture which is different not
actually better right
like we don't actually say the 613
commandments are necessary for everyone
there they're not necessary for people
who are not Jewish and to take that and
say okay now everyone has to abide by
those things would be a form of
totalitarianism a way that it is not
when you say we have this particular set
of values that is iterated to us in a
particular way okay but maybe we could
maybe we could think about it this way
maybe that would include both sides is
that there's a danger to claims of
universalism and that's that large-scale
totalitarian utopianism and maybe you
could you could criticize the
universalism of christianity as
contributing to that from a conceptual
perspective but maybe you could say the
same thing about the concentration on
the particular on the side of the of the
Jewish emphasis on on the state in that
because there are obviously pathologies
of ethno-nationalism and localization
that also manifest themselves as another
kind of danger right it would be the
danger of too much exclusion and the
danger of not enough exclusion right and
so the issue is how you get the
relationship between the individual and
the property correct yeah yeah yeah well
this is one of the things that I think
the EU is really struggling with is
because you know I'm kind of oddly
enough for someone who's Universalist
let's say I'm somewhat sympathetic to
the claims of the Nationalists in the
European Union because it seems to me
that what they're complaining about is
that as sovereign individuals there have
been levels of bureaucracy laid out in
this huge overarching structure the EU
that divorce them as individuals from
their masters right and they want a
local structure so that they have some
relationship with the structure right
and maybe you see in a place and
localism by the way with other human
beings I mean the fact is that you if
you didn't value your own child more
than you valued the child of a stranger
this would probably make a bad person
right right like we would actually it
wouldn't sit are you a bad person like
if it's definitely the other choice
between saving about trust being saving
my son and saving a random kid of the
same age and I said you know I don't see
any difference here do you think right
this would make me a bad person so the
idea of having societal bonds that are
local in nature it's one of the things
that America got right in some federal
structures the idea of localism localism
is very important as
one set of rules for everybody because
we do have these variations and those
variations allow us to have the social
fabric that's necessary you can't here
this is actually where I mean to bring
it full circle back to the online stuff
the online world is a giant savanna it
is just one huge plane right there's no
hierarchy in the online world and not
only that there are no pockets in the
online world on Twitter it's just one
huge plane that doesn't generate any
feeling of community what generates a
feeling of community is people who you
actually have social ties with and those
social ties are necessary social fabric
cannot exist for 6 billion or 7 billion
human beings social fabric exists in
your community hmm right and as large as
that community can grow and there are
limits to the growth of that community
and maybe this is what both Christianity
and Judaism have in common when it talks
about the Messianic era is there will be
a time when that social fabric can in
fact encompass everybody but that's not
something that that is naturally it
might also still be that it's still full
of particularity
exactly right it's just the entities
have to be have to be properly within a
current in the context right we like the
who are you in the sense that they have
a certain set of social values and as
the social values disappear we like the
EU less but those social values have to
be in common right so we all have to
have those in copyright the French don't
want to be English the English don't
want to be French and that's perfectly
okay they don't have to be French well
it's kind of nice that there are French
and English like that that's part of the
upside of diversity let's say is that
there is some genuine diversity and that
localism preserves that diversity and
this is what's so funny about the left
right the left will say that diversity
is our is our greatest benefit then they
immediately try to wash away everything
that is diverse about how people behave
except for at the same time they'll also
say well we should be more like
countries like Sweden and Norway and
Finland and bonus countries on planet
earth right I mean Lee yeah and by the
way there were plenty of people there
who are very worried about the
directions that their countries are
going these lefties in America saying oh
it's so great over there in the amount
of people that we met there that are
completely afraid of saying any
sweetener
there are immigration restriction asti's
it's so funny the left will talk about
the wonderful Sweden there's now right
but because of the backlash right
because of the backlash to massive
Islamic immigration into Sweden and they
and the fracturing of society in areas
like Malmo
as why all the Jews are leaving Sweden
no and
has elected a center-right government
specifically on the immigration issue so
yeah I mean to ignore him for me
individually and collectively the
biggest source of unhappiness for people
is pretending that reality isn't reality
when people fight reality they lose and
recognizing that reality is reality is
is necessary whether you're a nation
like Sweden or whether you are an
individual who's struggling with certain
realities like people's unhappiness
springs from thinking that reality is
mutable but they are immutable mostly
you're immutable and reality is not
mutable yeah alright I got I got one
more for you guys got about ten minutes
so let's go deep and personal with the
theme that we've run with here I want to
know a little bit about the adventure
you're both on we've been on this
adventure with you at least the last
couple of months but wait I've asked you
this before a couple of times and and
you always give me a slightly different
answer where does it come from within
you that you can do this and that's what
I want to ask you to like where does it
come from that you you sure you can know
all these things you could say all these
things you can read about all these
things but that you Jordan Peterson can
get out there every day put your ass on
the line take all the eight keep going
what what is it about you well the first
thing that we should point out is that
you know I have the same experience that
Ben has in public it's like I've had one
negative interaction in public and it
was minor and it was in Dublin with a
woman who was really drunk and it wasn't
even that bad you know but but I've had
thousands of personal interactions with
people and they're all unbelievably
positive they're not just positive like
they're people approach me and they're
very polite and they're often apologetic
because they think they're interrupting
me and you know then we have a brief
personal conversation and they talk
about how while they've been reading or
listening or whatever and that their
lives are up straightening out and that
that's really good and that they've
recommended the book and and so I'm very
happy about that and but it's just a
hundred percent positive and so and that
and it's an amazing and uplifting thing
to be able to go all over the world like
I was in Slovenia a week ago I think the
effect of YouTube by the way I think the
effect of YouTube and podcast is even
bigger in places where
the media isn't as reliable or well
developed as it is in the West it's hard
to say how how huge and in effect it has
but it's unbelievably big and so people
were stopping me all over and and it's a
remarkable thing to go into a new city
and have complete strangers approach you
in the most positive possible way and
then to tell you something private about
their lives and then to share with you
some triumph they've had it's like that
there's nothing that can be better than
that and then when we do these lectures
it's that on Moss right we have like two
thousand two thousand people come to the
auditoriums and very little of what
we've been discussing is being political
it's well except the way we've been
discussing politics you know the variant
of philosophical orientation said but
it's almost all centered on individual
development and so it's it provides a
kind of energy like in that and then
I've been in a more and more fortunate
position over the last nine months
because although I still find it very
stressful to have contentious interviews
with journalists like the GQ interview
for example they have their advantages
you know it's it's it's not like they're
a net loss in terms of promoting what
I'm trying to do which is try to help
individuals fortify themselves and then
so all of the elements of this that are
positive is enough to sustain this and
and to enable it to continue and and to
also make me think that there isn't
anything more relevant or meaningful or
adventurous that I could possibly be
doing feeding the meaning at the same
time finding through this is like it's
every night that we're out there there's
this like renewed sense of wow this is
real not just now putting it up and let
it go to the universe it's like we're
seeing these people and when that guy we
almost took off late from one flight
when that guy that was working at the
airline came up to you right in the
front row and was going on and on it he
could barely speak yeah and it was like
holy well you have people you know they
say well my my girlfriend and I decided
to get married now we're having a baby
because we've listened to your lectures
or here's here I'm here with my father
and we put our relationship that
happened the father and son who lived
we hadn't seen each other I think they
said seven years yep and they came to
yeah yeah yep and they were all smiling
away and like there's just endless
stories like that and I believe well I
believe two things I believe that the
individual is the fundamental local
locus of salvation and redemption I
truly believe that I don't think there's
anything that's more true than that and
then every time I see someone who's put
themselves together I think that's one
more major victory not minor you know
which is also why I'm always talking to
individuals in the audience and when
what we do these meet and greets
afterwards which kind of have this
commercial cheesiness about them you
know but but I don't care about that
because that's how it's that's how it
has to be that's how it has to be it's
it and it's set up so that it works I
meet a hundred and fifty people and I'm
very careful with every single person
that I interact with and the reason for
that is because I'm absolutely thrilled
that they're there you know they're
there they're there because they are
trying to not make things worse
minimally right and so you know one of
the themes that we've been discussing in
these lectures continually is that not
only do you have a moral obligation to
aim up and be good like and to pick the
highest value that you can conceive of
and pursue that honestly but that if you
don't do that to the degree that you
fail something that's hellish takes that
space and I really believe that like I
believe that since 1987 when I was
studying totalitarianism I realized that
it was the abdication of individual
responsibility in the final analysis
that led to the horrors of Nazi Germany
and the totalitarian communist states it
was on us each of us and so I thought
well then the thing to do about that is
to do whatever you can to strengthen
individuals and to make them more more
like appropriate moral agents not rights
not the individual rights but the
individual responsibility and I I truly
believe that that's how you keep hell at
bay and so there's a lot because I
really believe that there's a lot of
energy in that it's like I'm not
interested in having a replication of
what happened in the 20th century like
enough of that enough and so if if with
each person that's on a better path that
that probability decreases by 1 7
billion and
so be it and I think the effect is much
larger than that I think it's a network
effect I I don't I mean this is what I
was saying to you right before we
started I don't think we can really
understand how big it is because now
there's lectures you're doing your show
live I'm doing stand-up Rogen's doing
his thing Sam's doing all these things
and it's not just about us I don't want
to make it just about us but that there
is some other energy so when I talk
about the energy of destruction that's
out there I think there is a great
energy creation and I think we're part
of it I don't know how you're gonna top
that in know I'm not into a short form
which is I it's fascinating so I go out
in public as I say and a lot of people
want to take pictures and I'm sure
Jordan gets it as much more than I do
and when you do that it's you always
hear from people yeah you know I met
this celebrity on the street and they're
just jerks right like I'm an actor and
the actor was like miffed that they had
to get up from dinner yeah I have never
felt the experience where somebody
wanted to take a picture and I was not
delighted that they wanted to take a
picture and I think the reason for that
is not because like oh look at me I get
to be in this random person's picture
they puts on as well but because if you
actually believe that what you're doing
is a reflection of values that matter
it's not that they're engaging with me
mhmmm rights that they're engaging with
the idea is that I am that I am stating
and that's unbelievably exciting in my
entire life to espousing a certain set
of values and now millions of people are
engaging with those values and finding
those values meaningful this is why it's
hard for all of us not to sound arrogant
because we take our values so seriously
so when we say that maybe the hope for
the country lies in the fact that there
are so many people who actually watch
stuff like this I don't mean that
because I care if people if people were
watching me facepaint you know then I
don't think that that would have any
meaning for me but the fact that people
watch my show and that they're getting
some semblance of truth and values out
of it and what's it I will say it is
weirder for me I think it's probably for
me than it is for you Jordan because you
talk so much about self-help and about
individual help and all this kind of
stuff yeah because I'm a politics guy
and I spend most of my day breaking down
current events the fact that I get so
many people who emailed me and I send
them to my wife I send them to my my
parents because this is the stuff I'm
actually the proudest stuff is when I
get emails from people and I got one
today from some guy who said yeah I
knocked that my girlfriend and I didn't
know what to do about it and then I
started listening to your show and I
realized that for me to be a better and
more responsible human being I needed to
marry my girlfriend and we married now
for three years and my she was think
about getting an abortion
I listened your show she can get an
abortion now we have a kid and it's just
an amazing amazing thing like that's the
stuff that I care about I think politics
what I do for a living the politics
that's the stuff that's existing on top
of the iceberg and what I hope I'm doing
is talking about this in a sense that
allows people to draw a straight line
down to the bottom of the iceberg and
say okay well the real important stuff
is not what's happening the moment
investigation up here it's what's
happening in terms of truth and decency
and waiting for available evidence down
here to take one example and so every
news story is supposed to tie down into
the rootedness of a value system and the
fact that people are hungry for those
values that is what I'm really excited
oh yeah that's that's absolutely well
like you know I mentioned earlier the
tendency of the audiences to go silent
when I talk about the relationship
between meaning and responsibility and
that's well that's a sustaining thing
it's like look there's all these
thousands of people and what are they
starving for a heavy moral burden this
is right it's so amazing it's hanging
money yeah sometimes a hundred fifty
bucks a ticket what about look to hear
someone say fix yourself don't buy my
[ __ ] don't I'm not talking anything you
know there's a book but yeah but it's
like it's on you this is the reality of
the backlash because for thousands of
years it was the religious community
saying you have responsibilities you
have duty of responsibilities of duty
and then over the last hundred fifty
years people went no we're not gonna do
any of that stuff you know what forget
it and now people are going you know
that has some upside but it also has an
awful lot of downside none of us are
theocrats in the room I don't want a
religiously oriented society where
there's some king up top who's telling
everybody wants to do far from it but
people are hungry for a set of eternal
values and if they don't get those
eternal values they will find something
else to fill the hole here see anger or
it will be drugs or will be hedonism or
will be selfishness and in order to be
ideology or ideology and all of these
things and and I am an ideologue because
my ideology is my values but it'll be a
political ideology it'll be political
tribalism it'll be race-based stuff
it'll be ethnic and no centricity move
all those things what we're doing by
promoting a set of values that that
matter is we are allowing people to not
only keep the chaos at bay but
find a path amidst the chaos Steve
Viktor Frankl says in man's search for
meaning that in the middle of the
Holocaust what kept certain people alive
and why did certain people die he said
because if you were in the middle of the
Holocaust living the death camp it was
the people who found some sense of
purpose in the death camp who actually
got to live and how can you find purpose
in the most purposeless place in the
history of humankind he said it didn't
matter if human beings can find meaning
living in a living in a concentration
camp where people are getting gassed to
death every day then you certainly
should be able to find meaning in the
freest most rich most prosperous human
society in the history of humanity right
right right
that Shapiro is how you end it I will
add that I like when people come up to
me - of course Ben knows this there's a
girl who works at the hardware store
that's only a few blocks away from here
who always says to me Dave I'm a big fan
of yours but I really like that ben
shapiro all right guys I will be well
thanks to both you you're the religious
guy I will be at the Orpheum with Jordan
there can't be any tickets left right
for the other show Saturday but you
maybe can get him on StubHub or
something like that and perhaps a
certain Orthodox Jew will show up
because it's after Shabbat you never
know thank you miss possible all right
thank you guys for watching
you